>>> ISIS MILITANTS CAPTURED A
JORDANIAN PILOT.
THE PLANE WAS BROUGHT DOWN
DURING A COALITION AIR RAID OVER
RAQQAH IN EASTERN SYRIA.
NEW PHOTOS SHOW THE DAMAGED
PLANE.
RAQQAH IS ONE OF THE MAIN
TARGETS FOR THE U.S.-LED
COALITION IN SYRIA AND IRAQ.
THE CAPTURE IS A MAJOR SETBACK
FOR THE ANTI-ICE ACE SIS ALLIAN.
BAR BA STARR, ISIS RELEASED
PHOTOS OF THE PILOT.
>> VERY DIFFICULT.
THEY'VE RELEASED PHOTOS OF
OBVIOUSLY A TERRIFIED JORDANIAN
PILOT ENCAPTURED BY ISIS IN
RAQQAH.
RAQQAH, OF COURSE, IN SYRIA, IS
A MAJOR STRONGHOLD FOR THE ISIS
ORGANIZATION.
THE JORDANIAN ARMY, THE
JORDANIAN GOVERNMENT, EVEN THE
PILOTS AFAMILY CONFIRMING THE
IDENTITY OF THIS MAN.
NOW THE QUESTION IS, HOW WAS
THIS F-16 BROUGHT DOWN?
IS IT POSSIBLE THAT IT WAS SHOT
DOWN, AS ISIS CLAIMS?
NO CONFIRMATION ON THAT, BUT IF
THAT WERE TO BE THE CASE, THEN
IT POSES A REAL ISSUE FOR THE
COALITION.
HOW COULD ONE OF THE AIRCRAFT
BECOME VULNERABLE TO BASICALLY
WHAT WAS MOST LIKELY A
SHOULDER-FIRED MISSILE, THAT
BEING THE MAJOR WEAPON THAT ISIS
WOULD HAVE IN ITS INVENTORY IF
IT DID SHOOT DOWN THE F-16?
LOOK, WE REALLY DON'T KNOW.
THERE COULD HAVE BEEN A
MECHANICAL ISSUE, COULD HAVE
BEEN A WEATHER ISSUE, ANY NUMBER
OF THINGS, SO ALL OF THIS UNDER
RAPID INVESTIGATION BY THE
COALITION.
THEY WANT TO KNOW WHAT HAPPENED,
AND CERTAINLY BEHIND THE SCENES,
I THINK IT'S SAFE TO SAY THAT,
AS YOU WOULD EXPECT, GOVERNMENTS
ARE LOOKING AT WHETHER THERE IS
ANY WAY TO GET THIS MAN BACK TO
JORDAN, BACK TO HIS FAMILY.
THE JORDANIAN GOVERNMENT ALREADY
SAYING VERY